il ya déjà quelque chose de cossu et qui
flotte dans le mot même de paquebots
balcon blanc sur la mer c'est une rue
qui bouge et qui vive
et quand ça s'en va lentement du port
brandissant bien haut sa mâture en croix
où loger g10 à l'e3 le gabier barbu
chargé de crier terre dans les grandes
occasions
pendant un instant on ne sait trop si
c'est la terre qui se retire ou le
bateau qui s'éloigne environné de
mouettes et de poésie est muni d'un
certain nombre de certificats dont je
vous donne à toutes fins la liste un
permis de navigation français un permis
de navigation américain un certificat de
sécurité paquebot un certificat de
sécurité radio télégraphique et
radiotéléphonique un certificat de
dératisation ou si les rames déjà quitté
navire un certificat d'exemption un
certificat de francs bob deux
certificats du veritas 2 certificats du
llyod's un certificat de pesée des
bouteilles de co2 un certificat danalyse
de long et un certificat d'état main
oui
il
tous ces certificats ne dispensant pas
bien entendu d'emporter tout ce qu'il
faut pour distraire les passagers comme
ceux ci qui ne sont pas comme on
pourrait le croire en train de balayer
le pont mais de jouer au palais ce qui
est peut-être encore un peu plus
fatigant tout ce qu'il faut pour vivre
trois semaines sur la mer quand on ne se
nourrit pas de plancton
tout ce qu'il faut pour nourrir ce bébé
en anglais resplendissant comme un
soleil couchant à qui le chef mécanicien
fait risette avant de redescendre dans
la purgatoire des machines où il gagnera
son ciel en tout cas celui de l'escale
et sans compter entendu les piles et les
piles de pigeons d'argile qui vont être
nécessaires à la distraction favorite de
ce tireur d'élite
entendez de l'élite des premières
classes que les passagers ne se
lasseront pas de regarder manqué sa
cible
et tout cela suffit certificat compris
plus le reste que nous irons voir tout à
l'heure pour les rangs croisière avec
nous
du côté de la mer des caraïbes sur le
joli paquebot antilles
le compagnie générale transatlantique
sous la conduite expérimenté jeunes ans
par la dir exemplaire du commandant
delsart que vous verrez dans un instant
prenant le frais et bien sûr le vent sur
le pont supérieur en compagnie de son
état major
cela ne voudra pas dire bien sûr que le
bateau marche tout seul
voyez plutôt ce peintre qui peut se dire
à juste titre peintre en bâtiment et qui
posera sur son bateau plus de feuilles
de peinture que sur une automobile de
luxe
voyez aussi sur la passerelle se
timonier qui s'efforce de vous faire
marcher droit
en pesant sur sa gauche et sur sa droite
et non pas comme disent les terriens sur
bâbord et sur tribord
cet officier qui tâchent de savoir où
nous sommes avec un rapporteur et un
compas qui vont le lui dire peu à peu
par degré comme pour ne pas l'inquiéter
il est tous à pareille et toutes ces
machines
ce volant d'admission qui admet ou qui
n'admet pas la vapeur des chaudières et
tous ses cadres en a surveillé jour et
nuit
ce qui est d'ailleurs exactement la même
chose dans le royaume du soutien et
l'inclinomètre que vous venez de voir et
sans lequel il paraît qu'on ne saurait
pas si l'on penche à droite ou à gauche
coût
et les arbres d'hélices doré parle-lui
leur huile et qui tourne 166 tour
virgule 8 produisant une vitesse de 21
noeuds 90 moyennant une consommation à
décourager les usagers de l'autoroute
m
e
et après ces brûlures et après ces
chaudières cette centrale électrique ou
un spécialiste surveille la tension du
navire
et un peu plus haut les opérateurs qui
lance dans l'espace leur pépiements
radio télégraphique d'une phalange délié
qui devient subitement comment dirais-je
un peu gourde eux lorsqu'il faut taper à
la machine
ce qu'ici comme ailleurs les hommes
feront avec deux doigts
les autres servant à se gratter
l'oreille dans les cas de perplexité
dactylographique et enfin au dessus du
radar d' approche qui peut vous dire ce
qui se passe au delà de la ligne
d'horizon
ce radar de porcs qui vous mènera quai
par le bout du nez que d'hommes les deux
choses
deux techniciens et d'ingéniosité sans
parler du mazout il faut pour marcher
sur les eaux et laisser derrière soi
quelques secondes dans le soleil bleu de
la mer la trace éphémère d'un sillage